le dernier sujet est bien c'est
comprenez vous le geste du chauffeur
puisqu'on va parler de ce chauffeur du
bus de bus qui a giflé un ado tout le
monde en a parlé est ce que vous
comprenez le geste du chauffeur alors à
gâteau prouve vous êtes vous ai dit oui
vous dit non je comprends le geste du
chauffeur mais est vrai que de l'eau je
ne le comprends pas très l'approuvent
pas en tout cas alors c'est l'événement
qui fait le plus débat qui a fait le
plus débat sur les réseaux sociaux cette
semaine c'est bien entendu donc cette
affaire de la griffe 160000 réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux
cette actu qui a divisé toute la semaine
va être débattu pour retrouver le grand
gagnant de ce soir entre agathe eric
avant hausse un petit récap des faits
ces particules depuis dix jours un mot a
été prononcé des centaines de fois sur
les chaînes info j fully flared hi-fi
gif l'histoire de cette fameuse gifle
commence il ya dix jours à arcueil
lorsqu'un chauffeur de bus ratp a été
contraint de freiner en urgence pour
éviter de justesse un jeune homme qui se
trouvait au milieu de la route le
chauffeur sous le choc a tenu à sortir
de son bus pour s'expliquer mais à la
place de remerciement l'employé s'est vu
insulter par le jeune homme hors de lui
il a perdu le contrôle et giflé l'enfant
la vidéo de cet incident s'est
rapidement retrouvé sur internet ce qui
a valu au chauffeur une procédure de
licenciement
la ministre des transports elisabeth
board a réagi cette semaine et selon
elle cette gifle est un geste déplacé
est ce qu'il est normal de gifler un
jeune non ensuite les sanctions il ya
des commissions qui ont se réunir ce
moment qui vont obliger dakhla tôt et
mais très vite sur internet de
nombreuses personnes se sont indignées
de cette sanction une pétition a même
été lancée avec à ce jour plus de trois
cent mille signatures
alors comprenez vous le comportement de
ce chauffeur de bus alors c'est le match
final entre eric naulleau et à gâteaux
pour eric naulleau ne comprend pas le
comportement de ce chauffeur de bus un
gâteau proulx vous le comprenez c'est
parti une minute pour débattre donnez
nous votre avis où aussi c'est parti al
ghad vous démarrez alors sans évidemment
confessions et la violence que je ne
peux par dessus par dessus tout ne pas
cautionner c'est la défiance et le
mépris que subissent les travailleurs
publics et en premier lieu les
chauffeurs de bus ce ce jeune collégien
du haut de son mètre trente et de ses 12
ans à tandem était assez inconscient
pour avoir failli provoquer un accident
et au lieu de se rétracter ou même de
s'excuser il a invectivé le chauffeur de
bus en lui
sortant à ferme ta gueule et avance-t-on
bus donc moi c'est pas une gifle que
j'aurais misé c'est sans doute 46 ça m'a
mise deux mois marrant de sujets que
vous avez du temps oui effectivement
non mais ça m'a mis hors de moi et j'ai
eu tellement d'empathie pour ce
chauffeur méprisé que j'espère et je bus
exprime mon soutien comme toute sa
profession eric naulleau
mais parfois dans le métro dans un bus
on est soi même tenté de balancer une
gifle devant tel ou tel incivilités le
problème c'est que ce n'est pas le
métier de cet homme
if they gifle ce gamin en plus devant sa
mère ce n'est pas son métier il ya
d'autres gens pour prendre en charge ces
incivilités
ça c'est la première chose et ensuite
quelle va être la conséquence je sais
pas d'où vient ce gosse mais si le gosse
revient avec son grand frère ses grands
frères ses cousins et qu'ils exercent
des représailles sur cet homme qui en
effet est sorti des clous
parce qu'il a fait quelque chose qui
n'appartient pas à ces tâches qu'est-ce
qu'on va dire mais moi je suis pas là
pour juger si non elle son rôle pas son
rôle son métier passe on mettait ce
seuil pour comprendre ça c'est
l'hôtellerie de ben non le coeur du
débat c'est est ce que je comprends ce
comportement et c'est un comportement
pour moi humain et je comprends ce
comportement c'est pas une gîte gratuite
c'est une gifle après un accident qui a
failli être connu et c'est une juste
après une insulte
je la comprends vingt secondes pour eric
au camp mais on peut pas cautionner ce
genre de comportement parce que la vie
en société n'est pas basé sur la vente
d'état elle est basée sur la justice et
à la ratp de prendre ces décisions
et ce n'est pas à lui de prendre en
charge l'éducation de ce gamin devant sa
mère après le gamin ce qu'il a fait
c'est irresponsable mais simplement ce
chauffeur a clairement franchi la ligne
jaune ce qui pour un chauffeur est très
ennuyeux merci eric naulleau merci à
gâteau qu'on connaît
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous êtes contre cette
ville comme eric naulleau où vous êtes
pour agathe au cou alors salim sdiri vie
vous êtes vous êtes du côté d'agathe
bien chercher du côté la garde pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que j'ai été
président de la régie des transports de
marseille 1 1 6 et 1 rebond des sorties
on redescend pas du tout aussi j'étais
président d'un club des chiens
la difficulté de la profession de
chauffeur de bus ils se font insulter
toute la journée c'est vrai ces constats
toute la journée
là la réaction de ce chauffeur c'est une
réaction de père de famille
eric c'est pas une réaction et elle est
basée sur le sceau de l'émotion ce gamin
a failli se faire écraser
c'est humain il a eu une heure il a
traversé le chauffeur de bus a eu peur
quand tu es pris par l'émotion
tu ne maîtrises pas toujours effectuées
interac l'attend il est descendu excuse
moi je vais jusqu'au bout il se fait
insulter par le gamin tout ça non
seulement le gamay attend même puisqu'un
sultanat d'un adulte non je dis
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on reprenne la
société des adultes tu me servir le
respect oui la mairie car il ya plein de
respect ne parle de deux choses
différentes
qu'on essaye de comprendre mais c'est ça
le sujet dans mes à la caisse dans la
procédure disciplinaire je file atterri
dans la procédure disciplinaire qui soit
tenu compte en effet qu'il a agi sous le
coup de l'émotion mais tu me dis là
réagi en père de famille il n'est pas
père de famille il est chauffeur de bus